-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden kicked off
House Democrats' 3-day retreat
tonight
with a speech in Baltimore.
Well, it was supposed to be
a one-day retreat,
but when that guy gets
talking...
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
said this week
that federal agencies will
have to remove TikTok
from all government devices
in 30 days,
and if they're smart, Venmo.
Matt?
[ Laughter ]
In a post yesterday
on Truth Social,
Former President Trump accused
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
of wanting to cut
Social Security and Medicare,
and said he was a "wheelchair
over the cliff" kind of guy.
As opposed to Trump, who would
never waste a perfectly good
wheelchair.
[ Laughter ]
Mexican President Lopez Obrador
pushed back against criticism
yesterday of his recent
electoral reforms and said,
"There is more democracy
in Mexico
than could exist in
the United States."
Well, that's not the high bar
it used to be.
[ Laughter ]
That's like me saying I'm
a better tennis player
than Richard Kind,
who's backstage,
and we're gonna find out
when he comes out
if he thinks he can
beat me in tennis,
'cause I bet he probably could.
During oral arguments yesterday
in a case challenging
President Biden's student debt
forgiveness plan,
Supreme Court Justice
Neil Gorsuch
said the program was unfair
and failed to take into account
people who had paid off
their loans or never had them.
Yeah, can someone for once
think of the people
who never had student loans?
When do they get a break?
That's like saying no Tinder,
it's not fair to the people
who already get laid.
[ Laughter ]
Television provider Dish Network
confirmed yesterday
that a previous outage
was caused by
a cybersecurity breach,
and not, as customers assumed,
by a gentle rain.
[ Laughter ]
Dictionary.com yesterday
unveiled new entries,
including the word "woke."
"Still not gonna look it up!"
said Republicans.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida woman was arrested
last week
after she told deputies
during a traffic stop
she had drugs in
her body cavity,
and removed nearly 11 grams
of crystal meth.
Said the cops,
"Ma'am, we pulled you over
for a broken tail light."
[ Laughter ]
"Still, pretty impressive,
though, officers."
Fast food chain KFC
today announced
the return of the Double Down,
a bun-free sandwich
that substitutes bread
with chicken,
so you can substitute
hunger with self-loathing.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the pharmaceutical
company Eli Lilly
announced today that it will cap
the out-of-pocket cost
of insulin at $35 --
and not a moment too soon.
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
We're off and running.